una última protesta sonando sus cadenas
la activista maría kolésnikova y el
abogado máxima snap protestaron así tras
conocer su condena de 11 y 10 años
respectivamente
el gobierno de belarús los acusa de
pretender dar un golpe de estado
este veredicto es ilegal y sin causa no
se basa en pruebas
durante el proceso judicial no se
comprobó su culpabilidad ni los cargos
que les imputaron
los opositores fueron detenidos tras las
protestas antigubernamentales de 2020
que denunciaban un supuesto fraude
electoral donde alexander lukashenko fue
reelecto con más del 80 por ciento de
votos el juicio que se realizó a puertas
cerradas provocó varias reacciones en la
comunidad internacional
las condenas de mariah kolésnikova y
máxime snacks muestran que las
autoridades de belarús continúan su
asalto a los defensores de la democracia
y la libertad belarrús debe cumplir con
sus compromisos y obligaciones
internacionales dentro de la onu y la
osce la unión europea continuará sus
esfuerzos para promover la rendición de
cuentas por la brutal represión de las
autoridades
los activistas eran miembros del consejo
coordinador un grupo creado con el fin
de conseguir un traspaso de poder
pacífico
todos los miembros de este consejo han
sido encarcelados o han buscado exilio
según la organización vesna en ese país
hay más de 650 presos políticos el
presidente lukashenko dirige de la rush
desde 1994 con rusia como un aliado
clave para permanecer en el poder